this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by pdsdet
in December 1990 in a remote Village
above the Arctic Circle two Russian
scientists embarked on a daring
experiment their goal was to enhance
human super perception or ESP they built
a device that could Shield subjects from
electromagnetic interference and amplify
their biological energy the device was a
large tube of rolled aluminum with a
chair inside as soon as the device was
built strange phenomena occurred around
the village disc shaped lights hovered
around the lab balls of energy appeared
and disappeared the Northern Lights
became so bright and Vivid that they
seemed to have physical shape inside the
lab anyone who approached the device
felt an unexplainable sense of dread it
took a long time to persuade anyone to
try it when the first subject finally
sat in the chair a flash of energy
erupted that stunned everyone in the lab
the device worked but maybe it worked a
little too well not only did it boost
people's psychic abilities it also
enabled them to view any place in the
world and soon they could view any place
in time in fact these experiments
confirmed the theory first proposed in
the 1950s the time as we know it
doesn't exist
and when the crab cat arrives all
Guppies tremble at this
the Wiki's lag I've been two weeks on
duty the solitary life was a welcome
respite but my old ways have begun to
beckon me back did you just Finn dial me
yeah human I'm glad I caught you
okay I need an advance on my check I
gave you an advance when you hired those
Estonian mercenaries I know and it gave
you an advance to buy that land in
Scotland I know and I gave you an
advance to rent that submarine that was
work related so this would be an advance
on an advance on an advance
are you I've got a ton of past due bills
here credit cards personal loans
collections I mean who buys a fake
passport with a credit card I wasn't
and what's this one from the spearmint
goldfish
click click
it fills up the Wazoo I'm constantly
underwater it is hard to keep up with
the payments when I'm constantly in the
wind can't run away from debt really
tell me about it so about that Advance
okay one last time but you've got to
call PDS debt and let them help you with
all of this I got
it yep PDS debt rolls all your monthly
payments into one low zero percent
interest monthly payment everyone with
over ten thousand dollars or more in
debt qualifies
uh my credit score isn't so good most
companies don't look at a lake of
America as reputable than that well
there's no minimum credit score required
they take bad and Fair Credit and you
can save thousands in interest in fees
and pay off your debt in a fraction of
the time oh wait like the sound of this
as a matter of fact we do PDS is
offering a free credit analysis to
Watchers of the Y files just complete a
quick and easy debt assessment at
www.pdsdet.com files that's
pdsdebt.com files hey you're pretty good
at that uh you should host a show for a
living I host this show no I mean a real
show this this is not a
professional operation great very
supportive you know what
it's time for my shift well hang on you
have an important letter here from a
Ramona
well she says she wants to talk to you
about her son Jeffrey who was born this
past April April uh
oh no what I'm really gonna need that
advance
[Music]
the man did as the scientist told him he
stared at the curved wall of the
aluminum chamber and tried to picture
the ancient symbols that he studied
before entering wait a minute man what
what chamber what are you talking about
I'm talking about a study done in 1990
using a causer of mirror and why not
just say that well I was trying to paint
a picture you know theater of the Mind
theater out of mind yeah okay
stupid okay that's enough just tell the
people what's happening I'm trying to
tell them but you won't let me tell them
because you can't interrupt the man had
trouble concentrating the more time he
spent in the chamber the more he felt an
overwhelming sense of fear it was
instinctual it was Primal every fiber of
his being told him that he needed to
leave the machine now and never come
back then there was the dizziness and
nausea he felt a deep permeating
sickness everywhere Dr trevumov and Dr
kaznachive the scientists in charge of
the experiment told him this was common
and that if he could push through it he
would be okay there were a lot of
volunteers taking place in the study in
multiple sites in Russia they
communicated freely and openly and they
all had similar experiences after an
hour the nausea started to ease his
dizziness became something that felt
like floating and the feeling of
overwhelming fear became a feeling of
overwhelming calm his warped reflection
in the shiny concave wall started to
fade though that wasn't the right word
and he realized the wall was translucent
he could see through it but this
aluminum chamber was in a small concrete
lab in a remote Village in the Arctic
Circle but that's not what he saw
through the wall whatever it was that he
was seeing it was a sunny day he could
hear birds and children playing the more
he relaxed the more Vivid this Vision or
experience or whatever this was became
then without any effort at all he was
through the chamber wall and into the
vision it was like he was there it felt
real and even though he knew this was
impossible his instincts told him he was
there next he found himself floating
behind a child maybe five or six years
old he got closer and saw this was a boy
walking on a sidewalk somewhere the man
tried to look around to get a sense of
where he was but he couldn't tell it was
like the edges of his vision were
smeared but the boy the boy was in Focus
then the boy stopped the man floated
closer and recognized the boy's shoes
and he felt a wave of nostalgia the
boy's clothes too were familiar the boy
turned around and the man felt
electricity surged down his spine the
boy was him at five years old the
surroundings now came into Focus he was
a few blocks away from his childhood
home the sounds became clearer he could
hear distant traffic that he knew was
from a busy intersection a half mile
away the sound of children playing was
coming from a park nearby he turned and
saw the park and familiar faces playing
without realizing it his small aluminum
chamber faded away though he still had a
sense that he was connected to it
somehow somewhere and after a few
seconds of contemplating this experience
the man realized that the boys seemed to
be watching him but that wouldn't make
sense the day the man stepped into was
30 years ago
but then the boy said who are you whoa
in an instant the man snapped back to
the present day the portal closed and
the vision ended that was theater in
mind huh yes not bad that experience and
dozens of others are documented in the
case notes of this study and that one
isn't even the strangest
[Music]
foreign
as far as scientists go Nikolai kazarev
isn't exactly a household name but in
the early 20th century he was a
prominent Russian physicist whose
Innovative and controversial theories
are still debated today kazarev made
discoveries in astrophysics that were at
first rejected but later proven true in
1958 he reported volcanic activity on
the moon at first his claim was
dismissed by the scientific Community
later the Apollo lunar missions proved
kazareth was right
what moon landing Landing fake well the
volcanism was photographed by unmanned
missions to the Moon okay but later
confirmed when astronauts brought moon
rocks back to Earth
fake California
volcanic rocks yes in Burbank yes near
the movie studios
yes anyway kazareth conducted extensive
research on variable stars stars that
change brightness he claimed stars in it
torsion feels an idea that was
controversial how torsion is a
Cornerstone of kazarev's work and if his
theories are proven correct he might
have solved well everything torsion in
simple terms is the twisting of an
object due to an applied torque like
wringing out a wet cloth that's torsion
in action in theoretical physics torsion
is the twisting of space-time itself
you've heard of Einstein's theory of
relativity which describes gravity as
not a force but as the warping or
curving of space and time by mass and
energy now this is always shown with the
rubber Sheet example imagine a rubber
sheet stretched out that if you put a
bowling ball on it representing a
massive object like a planet or a star
it'll create a dip or curve in the sheet
then if you drop marbles onto the sheet
representing smaller masses they roll
toward the bowling ball that's general
relativity now the Einstein cartoon
Theory upgrades this Theory with a new
feature portion where the rubber sheet
or space time can be completely Twisted
an understand torsion imagine you're
holding one end of a slinky what works
downstairs a lot of wind Pairs and makes
a slickety sound a spring is freeing a
marvelous thing everyone knows a slinky
great now that's gonna be in my head all
day it's fun for a girl or a boy anyway
if you pull the ends of a slinky or a
spring it doesn't just bend it also
twists in a similar way the Einstein
cartoon theory proposes that the fabric
of space-time doesn't just curve due to
mass and energy it can also twist this
twisting according to Einstein comes
from the spinning of subatomic particles
but kosarev said that torsion is not
caused by particles it's caused by time
stick with me
mainstream science says space is empty
because of disagreed
he claimed there's an invisible medium
that fills the universe that he called
The Ether the idea of The Ether has been
around since ancient times but was
mostly abandoned after 19th century
experiments failed to detect it but just
because it wasn't detected doesn't mean
it's not there think about birds flying
in the air or fish in the water these
creatures need mediums to live and move
I prefer not to be called a creature but
I won't be a snowflake about it go on so
what about light traveling from a
distant star to your eye what medium
does it move through well mainstream
science says it moves through nothing
causerov said that's impossible the
medium is The Ether
there is not a static passive medium
it's Dynamic and interacts with
everything and time is not a passive
Dimension time possesses energy and
structure and this time energy flows
through and interacts with The Ether
just like a school of fish creates waves
and ripples and water time creates
ripples or waves of torsion in The Ether
hey it's the size of the fish
that's the motion of the ocean you know
what I'm saying does yeah
kosarev believed time is a physical
Force actively participating in the
universe's existence time is the
heartbeat of the universe it creates
energy that impacts matter and space and
because time has a physical structure
and energy it could have different
densities time can move at different
speeds time could be sped up slowed down
and can even move in Reverse we perceive
time as a river in our daily life we're
floating down this River with the
current of time carrying us from the
past through the present and into the
future but a river influences the
landscape it flows through and the life
that grows around it and in it time is
the same time energy influences
everything like gravity and
electromagnetism time also influences
physical matter including the earth and
the people who live on it time energy
influences the spin of galaxies and the
orbis of planets time energy feeds every
star in the universe and influences the
way they shine
time energy also influences the weather
on Earth the way plants grow and how
your DNA decided what color your eyes
would be now back to our raft if you're
in a raft on a river and you do nothing
you'll float along with the current but
with a little effort you can paddle the
raft to go faster down the river you can
make the raft stop though it takes work
you can also go backward against the
flow of the river and kazarev said time
works the same way we only perceive time
at our current Point as we float along
but the river behind us is still there
we pass through it but it's still back
there and the river ahead is there too
we're not aware of it until we get there
but it's still up there waiting for us
time like the river is always there past
present and future all at once when the
torsion from time energy ripples Through
The Ether that information is
transmitted instantaneously everywhere
the past the present and the future and
khazur have proved it
[Music]
he conducted experiments with pendulums
and gyroscopes to detect torsion fields
and time energy using a telescope Coster
have found a star the light from the
star is really from the past right the
light from a star ten thousand light
years away takes ten thousand years to
get here fine cozarev detected torsion
from that star ten thousand light years
away so that torsion was also from the
past next kosarev calculated where the
star was at the current time he detected
torsion there too in fact the reading
was much higher than the previous test
this means not only is torsion real it
moves much faster than light it's
instantaneous kosarev went a step
further he calculated where the star
would be in the distant future he
detected torsion there too Kaiser have
concluded that all time is simultaneous
and infinite that past and future are
just metaphors there is no past or
future there's only now he also believed
that an interaction occurs between time
and the human brain that's why there are
Concepts such as Intuition or foresight
this human consciousness tapping into
time energy but time can also be
influenced by human consciousness by
thoughts and by feelings which can
affect the physical world and because
time is a physical energy that can be
sped up or slowed down time can also be
concentrated and redirected khazarev
then unveiled a theory that shot the
world he said a mirror can be made that
can bend absolutely anything including
Time time travel is possible through a
mirror and then he built a machine to
prove it
foreign
is energy light which is electromagnetic
energy can be redirected with a mirror
time energy can also be redirected with
a mirror specifically causer I've used
concave mirrors and throughout history
concave mirrors have been used to
concentrate light the ancient Greeks and
Romans were familiar with this they used
polished bronze or silver concave
mirrors to focus sunlight and create
fire for various purposes these mirrors
known as burning mirrors were used to
light ceremonial torches and even ignite
sacrificial fires some mirrors were even
used as Weapons by reflecting sunlight
onto enemy ships that set them on fire
during the medieval and Renaissance
periods concave mirrors were used by
scientists and Alchemists to study
Optics and the properties of light Isaac
Newton used concave mirrors to
concentrate light in his telescopes
today concave mirrors are everywhere
they're used in Optical equipment like
projectors and headlights and
searchlights to focus and reflect light
concave mirrors are also utilized inside
like dishes to collect and focus radio
waves for communication kosarev said a
mirror was capable of bending almost
anything microwaves lasers ultraviolet
rays and even particles from space and
time energy can be focused the same way
kosarev invented and even patented a
device that would focus this energy it
was a thin sheet of metal bent into a
spiral using geometry based on Fibonacci
numbers like most naturally occurring
spirals are a spiral by the way is the
shape that results from torsion causerv
tested different metals and found that
time energy was most responsive to
aluminum his early prototype could
according to him Bend time at the
microscopic level through the device he
claimed he could see 10 seconds into the
future it was at this point that the
Soviet government classified his
research as a state secret his next
experiment was to build a larger version
it would be a capsule with the interior
wall entirely covered by this special
Mirror Time inside the capsule would
move faster if you were inside you could
see or even visit the future other
scientists throughout history may have
intuitively come up with the same idea
Nostradamus had his metal egg which was
nothing more than a wraparound concave
mirror and Nostradamus made his
predictions by gazing into a dark bowl
of water that he actually called a magic
mirror and of course a bowl of water is
a concave mirror in one of his notebooks
Leonardo da Vinci sketched what he
called the mirror chamber this was an
octagonal room where each of the eight
walls were made of Mirrors by the time
khazarev was building this new prototype
the Soviet government was keeping a very
close eye on the research the technology
also ended up on the cia's radar of
course it did and then on February 27
1983 just as he was about to test his
new machine oh no Nikolai kazarev
suddenly and mysteriously died
kidney
the secret Research into psychic
phenomena by American and Soviet
intelligence is not so secret anymore
the most famous American program was
Project Stargate this program explored
various psychic abilities but
specifically concentrated on remote
viewing which is trying to visualize a
distant Target using only the mind now
the results of project Stargate were
mixed but there were a few reported
successes the Soviet Union also engaged
in psychic Espionage and they invested
heavily in parapsychology and psychic
phenomena and the Soviets according to
Declassified CIA documents seem to have
been more successful in their attempts
the project we talked about earlier led
by Dr travumov and Dr kaznachive was one
of these successes the program began in
December 1990 at The Institute of
experimental Medicine of the Academy of
Sciences Siberian Branch the equipment
was assembled at a facility in Dixon the
northernmost settlement in Asia the main
piece of equipment is called a cause of
mirror based on Kazar research and
patents the mirror is a spiral-shaped
metal structure the size of a small
closet it's designed to capture and
focus psychic energy in the middle of
the Spiral there the occupant called a
psychonaut embarks on their psychic
Journey at least that was the plan as
soon as the khazure of Mira was built
strange events started occurring in the
facility and all over the town and
everything is documented in the book
Cosmic consciousness of humanity by
doctors kaznachive and travamov the book
includes interviews with test subjects
transcripts of recordings and
illustrations of everything that
happened during the study it's really
interesting and easy to read and down
below is a link where you can check it
out for free now as soon as the mirror
was activated the researchers noticed
that around the device was an intense
field of fear
[Music]
December 24th 1990 Abe won having
entered the room we felt a kind of
emotional pressure but we kept talking
as though we didn't care about it we
just couldn't keep standing around the
mirrors the fear was so strong more like
a wild Terror that couldn't be explained
it seemed like a real thing you could
touch none of this had ever had such a
feeling before
this feeling of instinctual dread was
described by some as something almost
physical that you could touch I had an
unpleasant feeling I felt cold and dizzy
my hands were trembling and my head grew
heavy even the air of the room seemed
different the fear was so strong it felt
like a substance it came from the
kazirab space and filled up the whole
room
at the beginning of the experiment
nobody wanted to go near the mirror once
we opened the door we got scared it was
a coming into cold water the shiver came
up as we got closer to the mirrors I
felt my head grow heavy as I approached
the fear grew so strong that I was close
to running away
powerful bursts of energy suddenly
appeared above the device the
researchers called them plasmoids and
the way they describe them they sound
like ball lightning and outside the
building objects started appearing in
the sky and these were seen by people
who worked at the lab as well as
residents of the Town coming to the lab
at 8 30 a.m I saw a red glimmering
circle above the building it was there
for a minute and then gone at 5 10 I saw
a UFO flying from the north the object
had the form of an ellipse radiating red
white light there are beams of light
coming off the object as if it was
searching for something the UFO remained
in sight for about four minutes then the
light went off and it was gone suddenly
I felt a kind of hypnosis the feeling
didn't last long I saw a white
glimmering object which looked like
Saturn against the dark sky seven
different UFOs were seen for months all
over the area finally some participants
of the study worked up the courage to
enter the kazarev mirror and that's when
things get really strange
[Music]
foreign
here's how the first experiment Works an
operator sits in a causative mirror at
the lab in Dixon another person sits in
a mirror at the town of novosibirsk 1400
miles away the operator is then told to
concentrate on a symbol and send that
symbol to the receiver in novosibirsk
and the results were surprising on days
when the Earth's magnetosphere was quiet
the success rate was between zero and
ten percent but when the magnetosphere
was active like during solar storms the
receiver could successfully detect the
image being sent by the operator between
30 and 45 percent of the time it seemed
like human consciousness was somehow
connected to the Earth's magnetic field
now this completely aligns with Nikolai
kosarov's theory that sunspots and solar
weather amid torsion waves that have
far-reaching effects and these waves
influence many processes on Earth from
weather patterns to human consciousness
so another experiment was done this time
two operators and two different kazarev
mirrors in two different cities
we concentrate on sending images into
the Earth's magnetosphere then 5 000
participants in 12 countries around the
world would try to tune into this energy
and view the symbol being sent when the
magnetosphere was active the success
rate jumped to 95 not only did this
shock the scientists running the
experiment but it also shocked the CIA
who had been watching closely and it
turned out that children specifically
female children from spiritual and
shamanic families were extremely good at
this during one test rather than
thinking of an image the mirror Operator
just thought of a number the children
were able to receive this number look up
the image and draw what they saw for
symbol number 63 this is what they drew
[Music]
and for symbol 32 this was seen
over the next few months volunteers
learned to tolerate the causer of mirror
device for longer periods of time and
some people stayed in for seven hours or
more being inside kuzured Space At first
I felt my body shaking to and fro I felt
pressure from all around my head grew
heavy later this feeling went and I and
I felt so light it was like I was coming
out of myself
when they were inside the mirror they
started calling this kazarev space and
when they were in kazur of space
participants were feeling and seeing the
same things at first I felt my head grow
heavy it was also shaking a bit and then
it was gone I saw people's faces
flickering in my eyes then I saw black
clouds it was like I was falling through
a black hole
almost everyone felt weightless and then
like they were flying I felt waves
coming over my head that it felt like
there was somebody else in the room and
then there was a series of images
[Music]
in their book travelmov and kaznachieve
included a chart of common experiences
almost 90 percent of participants felt
like they were flying most saw outer
space celestial bodies and even UFOs
during longer sessions another strange
phenomenon was common visualization and
the manifestation of symbols people
started seeing symbols hovering in the
air and they're described as swirling
and floating around the room and each
symbol emits an eerie glow like neon but
people weren't seeing these symbols in
their minds the symbols were appearing
in the room even more amazing people who
were completely isolated from each other
were seeing the same symbols two
thousand distinct symbols were recorded
a linguist researched them and found
that 80 percent of them came from
ancient cultures in fact the most
frequent symbols were from ancient
Sumerian the experiments continued for
months and exceeded all expectations
participants of the study who
experienced kosarev space found that the
effects lasted for a long time after
leaving the mirrors people were thinking
more quickly scoring higher on IQ tests
they had increased memory capacity they
were more creative some people had
illnesses that were completely cured
doctors travelmov and kaznachive
believed this technology was a
breakthrough that could Elevate all
human consciousness if the technology
was handled carefully and responsibly
the scientists were very aware that
using kazarev mirrors to activate
superhuman abilities could be dangerous
the CIA shared the same fear there was
also another issue that had them worried
it turned out that when people were in
causative space
they weren't alone
[Music]
more time people spent in kazraab Space
the more they realized they were all
having the same experiences 75 percent
of people saw UFOs 70 saw
extraterrestrial buildings and 68 of
people felt the presence of intelligent
entities in causer of space they started
calling these entities The Observers I
felt a kind of discomfort which then
turned into fear I felt I had something
cold right on my neck I had a feeling
somebody was watching so I was afraid to
open my eyes
this Observer could physically interact
with people within kazarev space I
closed my eyes I wanted to sleep but all
of a sudden I felt somebody touching my
hand my body shivered with fear
The Observers were consistently
described as humanoid but not human they
were very bright like made of light no
one was able to make out any features
being inside causer of space At first I
felt nothing at all in a few minutes I
saw a human shape it was white all over
in 30 seconds it was gone
on a few occasions an observer actually
communicated between the mirrors I felt
my head jerk and something appeared I
was asked who's that man with you I
explained that he was a scientist that I
asked them who are you no answer came I
asked them can you be seen and I saw
human shapes I saw shining lights I
Heard a Voice asking me what do you want
I answered I want to meet you I only
remember one word of the answer League
most participants found communicating
with The Observers to be an unpleasant
experience
I saw a device with lights and an edge
shaped object this ran in my mind
come up I answered I don't want to I
have fear of you that it was gone I
am slowly there were flashes of life I
asked who was there the answer was I
have no face I am nothing and everything
then I saw the eyes the eyes were not
very kind
a few people saw more than UFOs in the
sky they saw UFOs from the inside I saw
a light on which I could manage to get
to a flying craft it was a black
hemisphere I saw a few doors I opened
one door and found the beings with human
but but of smaller size I asked them
what they were doing and they answer
they kept watching us I asked them where
they were from they said they came from
a big star
and one Observer had a disturbing
prediction for Earth my body got relaxed
and light as soon as I closed my eyes I
saw an object flying above then I was in
a room I hadn't seen before a man was
standing in the center of the room his
face wasn't seen he began to speak
slowly your planet is in dangerous it is
suffering you have been in the mirrors
too much it's bad then he said there may
be a disaster I asked him when no answer
came
now it's unclear whether this Observer
actually saw the disaster in the future
or was just saying that we're on a path
to disaster but time travel was
experienced by over 40 percent of the
participants now most of those
experiences were the person at various
stages of their life some view their
life like watching a movie others were
actually able to interact with and
participate in their life in the past
also there were many people who observed
or participated in historical events one
woman remembers being an advisor to
Genghis Khan another felt his
Consciousness transfer to someone in the
Middle Ages another to the Roman Empire
remember Nikolai kosarov believed that
time was energy and he believed that
time energy could carry information to
and from the physical world information
was specifically abundant when objects
changed their state for example when
water freezes solid and then melts and
then turns into steam this changing of
state is very effective at encoding time
energy the site in Dixon was chosen for
a few reasons but one of those was
permafrost the researchers believed that
when the water in the Arctic froze
information from that time it was frozen
stayed trapped in the ice and when the
ice melted that time energy was released
they thought some people may have tapped
into this time energy which gave them
access to different points in time now
all this research is documented and
available and it's linked below I'll
also link to a Russian documentary that
covered this pretty well now doctors
cast and Achieve and travelmov continued
their work with kazarev mirrors for
years and achieved an incredible amount
of success but despite the support of
the Soviet and Russian government's
mainstream science journals wouldn't
publish the work in the west Research
into causer of mirrors has been
completely ignored by everyone except
the CIA right within the past couple of
years the CIA has released a few
documents showing that they were
following This research very closely and
it's been alleged they've conducted
their own research into kazarev mirrors
there's one last document in the CIA
database that cover mirrors and the
potential for this technology to unlock
human psychic abilities and awaken human
consciousness but that document despite
many Freedom of Information requests
remains classified
the research done in Siberia in the 90s
using kazarev mirrors is amazing but is
it true well it's a difficult story to
debunk on one hand mainstream science
doesn't take any of this seriously on
the other hand major intelligence
agencies do Dr Kazan achieve and Dr
trevumov published their research in
detail they've given plenty of
interviews they say all of this happened
and they don't seem to be lying and why
lie remember their early research was
funded by the Soviet state and lying to
that government seems unwise but if
their technology works why isn't it more
widespread you absolutely can buy
kazarev mirrors you can buy blueprints
to build your own the process is well
documented there are even a couple of
patents the materials are not that
expensive still it's a technology that's
way On The Fringe now whether you
believe in the cause of mirror or not
comes down to do you believe Nikolai
kazarev's theory about time energy and
The Ether mainstream science doesn't
believe in anything called The Ether
but if instead of ether kosarev called
it dark matter or quantum foam or
emergent space maybe more people would
have accepted his ideas because of head
of few ideas rejected by mainstream
science that were later proven to be
true what if he's right about this too
but using a mirror to reflect time that
sounds very science fictiony and it was
until last month scientists at the
advanced science research center at the
City University of New York conducted an
experiment they sent an electromagnetic
wave through a meta material these waves
also have a Time component that can be
measured the wave went in moving forward
and came out moving backward this is
what's called a Time reflection and this
was pure Theory until now so Nikolai
kazarev was right time isn't as linear
as we thought kosarev also said time
affects everything in the universe
physically well Dr travamov has been
using kosarev's theories and causer of
mirrors to predict earthquakes again
sounds like science fiction but
geologist's accuracy in earthquake
prediction is on average eight percent
in 2018 travamov's accuracy was as high
as 61 percent according to travelmov we
can use kasarev mirrors to predict
dangerous weather volcanic eruptions and
even solar storms causer of mirrors
could be used to study our solar system
or even deep space we can use it to look
for landing sites or help us search for
extraterrestrial civilizations causer of
mirrors can be used to slow down the
rate of Aging in the human body and cure
incurable diseases
[Music]
now despite all this potential
mainstream science won't take this
technology seriously travelmov and
kaznachieve said this technology is so
important and so profound that it should
be made available to everyone and not
left in the hands of an elite few kazner
Chief specifically worried about
government or corporations abusing cause
rep technology and I think it's fair to
worry about that but I also think it's
worth the risk kosarev's Theory whether
real or not has a great message for
Humanity that we're not bound by fate or
determinism but have the potential to
shape our own reality with our choices
and actions it reveals that we're all
connected to each other and to the
universe through subtle fields of energy
and information and I'd like to have
access to that information wouldn't you
I think we all of us should download the
plans grab some sheets of aluminum and
see what we can discover because there
are only two options democratize this
technology so everyone can have access
to it so we can all explain government
and exchange knowledge perhaps allowing
the entire human race to take an
evolutionary Leap Forward or option two
kosarev's technology remains classified
and under the control of the CIA
not a hard choice for me so I don't know
what your plans are this weekend but me
I'm going to Home Depot
want to come with
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is AJ that's cycle fish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do him a favor and
like comment subscribe share I know
those things are annoying but it's just
a button and it really helps and like
most topics we cover on this channel
today's was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips a special thanks to our patrons who
make all this possible you guys are
amazing and I couldn't do this without
you now if you'd like to join an amazing
Community consider joining our Discord
it's free to join and it's fun and
everybody's great but if you'd like to
support the Channel with money that's
helpful too you can become a patreon
member for as little as three dollars a
month but if you'd like to get something
you can touch like stuff buy something
for the Wi-Fi store oh grab yourself a
heck of his T-shirt I went into the
future and found out they're gonna be
highly valuable collectors items is that
true he proved me wrong that's gonna do
it until next time be safe be kind and
know that you are appreciated
[Music]
foreign